Oh Diplo what's up man I'm the guy I
guess you know I'm glad cuz I get to
talk to you guys I mean thank you I
appreciate that
much love for sure how you looking so
sharp what's up I'm sure by every red
carpet on Matt you guys are just you
know fluffing my ego thank you very much
I was gonna say I see you product hold
the turtleneck yeah that's easy talk
about your outfit what inspire him I we
just came back from Africa so you know
I'm still in the I'm still an African
mind frame you know well big up to
everybody out there that loves a good
guys Latin Grammys do you feel the
energy I mean how does it feel to be
here on this red carpet with more red
than ever man you know it feels great I
feel like we're gonna lose tonight but
it's alright because we're here
participating with all our friends and a
lot of these guys are friends now
Rosalia valve and bad bunny who made so
many records Carole gee this year so as
good is to be part of this movement it's
a movement right that's what it feels
like this this wave this explosion of
Latin music so how badly do you win you
could be honest it sounds like you
really want it where we're gonna go
against rosalia and Jay bellman and
Beyonce together so if somehow we win I
don't know when someone someone lost
some ballot somewhere but we're good
where were the needs of tonight so she's
she's nominated us so we got her her
star power these your star power you
just mentioned Beyonce I know you
produce some tracks for Queen B I mean
what's it gonna take for you guys to
make some magic again maybe get you
involved this time with her it's a
mystery we don't even know you're having
a record on her album till like 12 hours
of force released so she should do
something different like go in another
direction I feel like you can help her
do that I mean she always a trendsetter
I just hope that the more people get to
hear the albums because last time we did
it we didn't get all the streaming
services so the lemonade but I think but
I think I think definitely she's an icon
so whatever she does it's always setting
turns speaking of icons Marc Anthony
tonight is opening the show with Will
Smith and bad bunny right crazy right
that's actually like
probably the highlight at night no doubt
yeah this person is spent astonished
because I've watched his our instagrams
he's definitely listening to those uh
like audiobooks I think yeah rosetta
stone huh quickly uh tonight guys how
you gonna celebrate you know it's a no
matter win or lose it's gonna be a party
night don't you think
well she's gonna turn it up we're
talking while we're invited thank you
we're happy to invite it because you
they said win or lose they're hanging
out with you and it's gonna be a good
night I got I'm gonna rent out the
t-mobile Arena we're gonna have a party
yeah he was definitely involved no
matter what tonight okay but I'm not I'm
doing I think about it I think you're
winning just by being here and being the
most beautiful woman on the red carpet
gorgeous so you haven't prepared a
speech then you're just gonna enjoy the
night what's your plan I prefer to don't
prepare okay she's witty too smart well
congratulations you guys Oh who's who
you're wearing by the way this is me bag
was like it's somewhere shopping did
tell me she was gonna wear a pink latex
outfit I'm looking at it now like no you
went with the feathers cuz it's Vegas
when your little showgirl moment my
things are not here so my sister went to
the shopping mall to buy right I just
bought this shirt are you guys have fun
tonight alright Cheers